salut aujourd'hui on est samedi c'est
donc le jour du master class et je dis
je vous ai dévoilé quel master class
j'allais faire il ya beaucoup de bruit
il faut quand même que vous sachiez
pourquoi je vous emmène avec moi
j'explique aux gens pourquoi il ya du
bruit chez moi par contre si vous faites
attention vous reconnaissez et ses
excuses jeanne ou et georges titia de le
corps la maison l'esprit que vous avez
vues dans la vidéo et je m'en suis
toujours pas remise la vidéo des rubik's
cube et où jamais de la vie dure et vous
pour essayer de comprendre j'ai par
contre ya moi évidemment mais on ne
présente plus puisque évidemment je suis
une incontournable de mon salon je vais
quand même essayer de parler plus fort
qu'elle parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est très
important je vais vous apprendre à
compter les cartes au casino pour gagner
au black jack en tout cas pour moi
perdre au jeu du blackjack attention
c'est pas une vidéo non plus pour
tricher aux cartes au jeu du black jack
je vois ça comme quelque chose de très
intéressant je vous le dis je me tiens
pas pour responsable de ce que vous
allez faire de ce savoir-faire après je
vous déconseille formellement d'utiliser
cette technique là dedans les casinos ne
le faites pas vous pouvez vous entraîner
pour vous parce que c'est intéressant
comme jeu de l'esprit vous pouvez le
faire entre amis si c'est pas des jeux
d'argent parce que les jeux d'argent
sont interdits en fin bref vous avez
bien compris mon but c'est pas vous
apprendre à tricher mon but c'est vous
faire découvrir une technique
intéressante liées aux jeux de blackjack
la chaussure de parler en prison retour
rapide sur ce qu'est le blackjack le
blackjack c est un jeu de cartes
évidemment on peut être plusieurs
personnes contre un croupier et les
joueurs ne sont pas les uns contre les
autres en fait les joueurs sont
individuellement contre le croupier
d'ailleurs il ya des techniques dans ma
part les terrains ce trépied un copain
qui est croupier des ententes entre le
joueur qui joue en fait entre eux comme
une stratégie pour battre le croupier
mais ce n'est pas le propos
d'aujourd'hui au blackjack
on vous sert des cartes est votre but
est d'avoir plus gros que la banque en
fait plus gros que croupier le croupier
on va l'appeler la banque qui durant
toute cette vidéo admettons donc vous
devez avoir flux gros que la banque pour
gagner sur la banque le score maximal
est de 21 21 c'est ça le blackjack
encore vous êtes au dessus du 21 si vous
avez brûlé vous avez perdu d'office je
rende pas plus précisément dans les
règles
je suis jamais vous les connaissez pas
vous les trouvez partout sur internet
faut savoir qu'il existe une stratégie
de base très élaborés pour gagner au
blackjack c'est une stratégie qui a été
améliorée d'ailleurs dans le temps au
fur et à mesure et cette stratégie elle
explique exactement quoi faire quelle
méthode adoptée en fonction de toutes
les situations vous allez rencontrer au
blackjack cette stratégie a été créé au
fil des années pour que les avantages de
la maison soit proche de zéro
l'avantagent de la maison celle
avantages du casino en fait le black
jack est un des jeux qui permet d'avoir
l'avantagé le plus proche de zéro voire
même à zéro c'est à dire que si on
respecte bien cette stratégie on ne peut
quasiment pas perdre d'argent en fait et
alors pourquoi le casino games il
comment ça se fait qu'il se fait de
l'argent c'est surtout que oblet déjà
comme un n'importe quel jeu à un moment
donné on se laisse prendre par nos
émotions et on ne ne réfléchit plus on
ait pu raisonner à vous savez ces jours
on y par exemple là je le sens bien là
c'est maintenant que je vais gagner
c'est maintenant en général c'est
surtout maintenant que vous perdez tout
d'un coup et s'est terminée la stratégie
de base
elle permet surtout ne pas perdre
beaucoup d'argent voire de pas en faire
du tout mais c'est pas ça qui vous en
fait gagné en réalité parce que ces
méthodes de sûreté ont parisdamis
minimum est donc la seule manière
d'optimiser ça c'est de compter les
cartes compter les cartes c'est très mal
vu un évidement par contre en exercice à
faire vous pour vous derrière la caméra
chez vous c'est forcément hyper
intéressant dans ce master class je vous
parle du système hi lo au bail à
d'autres systèmes comme le high up 2
comme le oméga de il y en a il y en a
beaucoup d'autres en fait qui permet
vraiment de compter les cartes au
blackjack c'est que c'est un système
prévisible c'est à dire qu au blackjack
on va prendre un jeu de cartes et on va
passer les cartes unes à unes on va les
distribuer et claires et elles ne sont
pas remises en jeu donc est ce qu'on
appelle un passé un présent et un futur
le le passé c'est l'écart qui sont passé
le présent c'est ce qu'il ya sur la
table actuellement et le futur c'est
tout ce qui reste et le conte permet de
prédire le futur de savoir ce qui va
arriver
en tout cas de pouvoir rendre la
probabilité plus forte en votre faveur
dans les casinos ou les endroits on joue
vraiment au blackjack on n'utilise pas
casser le jeu on en utilise plusieurs
par exemple 6 et souvent pour rendre le
compte un peu plus compliqué hein
et un peu plus difficile on plante une
carte comme ça dans le milieu de tout
l'ensemble des jeux et on se dit arriver
à cette carte on remet tout en jeu et on
remet l'ange tout c'est un peu contre
les compteurs c'est pour ça qu'il est
très difficile maintenant de compter
dans les casinos d'une manière favorable
ça fait bien longtemps qu'ils ont vu les
compteurs arrivées sont pas fou non plus
pour vous expliquer un peu plus en
détails je vous faire voir les cartes
france vers le col drogue du pauvre mais
j'ai l'impression d'être tout petit
maintenant donc le système à hulot
consiste à tenir un compte en permanence
de ce qui est sorti dans le jeu alors on
va pas compter les cartes on peut pas
les retenir comme ça par contre on peut
retenir quelles sont les cartes forte
passé les faibles passé ou celles qui
sont ne passe que le high low se découpe
en trois catégories de cartes les cartes
forte ce sont les attributs
alors qu'est ce qu'une bûche aussi c'est
du jargon des cartes oman les juges se
sont ces cartes là le dise le valais la
dame et le roi et las le roi la dame le
valais et lui disent valdi point où la
jac hélas sabots 1 ou 11 mais non
s'attacher au fait que l'as vo 11 et
donc la manière la plus rapide de faire
humble à jack c'est d'avoir une bûche et
un as 21 blackjack je gagne je m'énerve
beaucoup trop je fais tomber deux cas il
y a également les cartes neutre ce sont
les sept l'es8 et l'es9 et enfin les
petites cartes l'écart est faible 2 3 4
5 et 6 ça ce sont les cartes feront le
système hi lo est basé sur ces trois
catégories donc retenez bien ça les
cartes offertes valent moins 1
donc les as et les bûches les cartes
neutre elles valent 0 donc 7 8 9 et les
petites cartes 2 3 4 5 6 voilà je veux
vous rajoutez 1,6
ça ça vaut cru ce 1 une fois que vous
savez ça vous savez tout durant toute la
partie vous à les additionner les moins
les héros les plus sains pour connaître
le compte de ce qu'on appelle le rc en
permanence c'est ce rc là c'est ce
compte là c'est sûr résultat qui va vous
dire si vous devez miser plus ou pas
tout en suivant la stratégie de base
sinon certains tellement d'intérêt un
bref quoi que si si ça a toujours un
intérêt en fait de connaître le compte
est de se dire je vais miser plus
fortement à ce moment-là piquer nos
payes trois pour deux roues la jac c'est
à dire si je me sens et que je gagne je
gagne 150 ans fait donc il est il ya
intéressant de parier vraiment plus
au moment où le compte et au parce que
si le compte et au ça veut dire que
beaucoup de petites cartes sont passés
ça veut dire qu'il reste beaucoup de
buts et das dans le jeu ça veut dire que
vous avez de fortes chances de faire un
black jack ou alors vous avez aussi de
fortes chances que la banque brûle ça
aussi c'est intéressant c'est une
manière de gagner parce que là la banque
alors ça ça dépend des casinos ça dépend
des pays ça dépend des règles mais ça
doit être annoncée à l'accueil par
contre devant la table doit retirer des
cartes en permanence tant qu'elle n'a
pas dépassé un certain compte
ok si elle met ton elle doit elle tire
jusqu'à 16 ça veut dire que si elle est
à 15 allait obliger la banque est
obligée de prendre une autre carte mais
si vous vous savez que le comté au ça
veut dire qu'il reste beaucoup de
grosses car dans le jeu est donc mis à
fortes chances il brûle on prenait un
petit peu le principe pour connaître ce
compte donc vous allez toujours
additionner en permanence vos cartes
celles des autres joueurs qui est sur la
table est forcément celle du croupier
démonstration pour c'est un petit peu
plus clair si je retourne là je compte 1
parce que c'est une petite ensuite deux
parce que c'est encore une petite
3 parce que c'est une petite je reviens
à 2 parce que là je mets moins un pour
celle ci revient à 1 parce que là c'est
encore moins un pour celle ci là ça fait
toujours un parce que c'est 0-1 parce
que c'est zéro là je reviens à zéro
parce que c'est encore moins un
là par exemple tous à mon compte final
de tout ça c'est 0-1 compliqué il faut
juste s'entraîner il faut bien sûr
connaître les cartes parker avec les
correspondances par coeur pour les moins
en mai +10 celle de devenir un
automatisme en fait vous n'avez pas à
réfléchir parce que là autant on peut
prendre son temps à attendre dans une
partie vous n'avez pas du tout le temps
de prendre votre temps ça va très vite
les cartes sont ramassés très vite ça va
à une vitesse incroyable ça doit devenir
des réflexes en réalité le raccourci
vous l'avez avance de travail c'est
juste de visualiser de faire des
déductions au lieu de compter je vous
montre par exemple l'âge et une première
main qui vaut zéro instantanément je
vois une fortune feb jeu ça n'existe pas
en fait dans mon ensuite je continue à
retourner ici j'en ai deux j'ai vraiment
un plus d'eux parce qu'il ya deux
petites et là je retourne ça là celle ci
pour moi elle ça nul on a une forte les
voyez bien en fait
parce que si vous ne voyez pas je
m'oppose à bord rien lassé de la health
annuler parce que j'ai une forte et
faible ça c'est zéro ça compte pas donc
en fait de cette table là je ne retiens
que celle ci je retiens que plus un vous
voyez ce que je vais vous dire un petit
peu se dire j'ai pas fait ça plus à plus
à plus à plus à plus j'ai fait tiens ça
ça s'annule ça ça s'annule
compte pas tu ne me reste plus un en
adoptant cette méthode là évidemment
vous balayer la table comme ça d'un
regard et vous savez exactement où en
est votre compte pour vous entraîner le
plus simple c'est de prendre un jeu
comme j'ai vous enlevez les joker s'il
ya des joker évidemment et vous passez
des cartes comme sa une à une et vous
tenez le compte
alors après vous pouvez le faire de plus
en plus rapidement évidemment et puis
vous pouvez aussi vous laisser distraire
et je peux compter les cartes très très
vite d'ailleurs si je compte jusqu'au
bout les cartes je vais arriver à zéro
non pas du tout en train de compter mais
parce qu'un jeu entier équivaut à 0 au
final il ya un équilibre parfait entre
les moyens les plus sains et les neutres
vous pouvez aussi vous laisser distraire
en mettant de la musique très fort la
télévision la musique dans les oreilles
en parlant avec quelqu'un au téléphone
c'est très important d'essayer de
dissocier son compte d'une discussion on
peut discuter en comptant puisqu'on
compte pas vraiment
rappelez vous comment j'ai fait
j'élimine et des pères ou alors aussi de
retourner les cartes comme ça deux par
deux et de devoir tenir le compte tout
en maintenant comme ça un peu comme vous
pouvez le faire en alternant vous pouvez
le faire simultanément la seule vraie
méthode en fait c'est de s'entraîner de
s'entraîner de s'entraîner de
s'entraîner et ça va très très vite
rentrer après ça devient naturel
puisqu'on parle de compter les cartes
mais on ne les calcule pas réellement on
va pas dire que c'est un calcul
compliqué de faire moins 1 0 et plus et
quand est-ce qu'on mise et mais ça
dépend du rc plus le rc et au plus au
dessus de 2,3 plus on dit que le sabot
est chaud c'est à dire que le sabot va
donner des grosses car on peut donc dire
qu'à partir de deux je vais commencer à
miser un petit peu plus parce que le
sabot à pierre choffé si le verset
faible au contraire c'est à dire s'il
est dans les nombres négatifs si vous
avez un compte à - 1 - 2 - 4 - 6 peu
importe ça veut dire que là qu'il ya
beaucoup de petites cartes qui vont être
à venir
il faut miser au minimum même mieux il
faut partir de la table de jeu si c'est
possible
vous pouvez y rester si vous suivez la
stratégie de base ou jouer les musées
minimum bon perdre et pas grand chose et
si le rca 06 le comté à 0 ça veut dire
que le sabot est neutre il est
complètement neutre on ne peut rien
anticipé en fait on est comme un début
de partie en fait c'est la même
situation donc si vous connaissez la
stratégie de base encore une fois joué
là sinon je vous hais la mise minimum
vous avez juste c'est à retenir quand le
comté hausse et que
vous avez l'avantagé joueurs faisaient
donc parler du verset leur running
compte en fait c'est le conte qui court
en fait le compte
actuelle il ya une autre théorie en fait
qui est sûr le tc en fait le compte réel
alors tout le monde n'utilise pas en
fait mais c'est un homme intéressant à
connaître c'est pour ça quand même que
je vous en parle
rt vous prenez votre compte actuelle le
rc donc et vous allez le diviser par le
nombre de jeux que vous estimez qui
reste dans le dans le sabot si vous
estimez qu'il reste une centaine de
cartes donc à peu près deux jeux de
cartes vous allez diviser le rc par deux
c'est à dire que si votre compte
il est de 4 ans versée si on prend le rt
ça voudrait dire qu'il serait plutôt de
2 c'est une théorie intéressante qui est
en tout cas d'un des meilleurs résultats
au final que le rcd pure mais l'inversé
est très bien aussi en fait le le rc
seul et très efficace aussi mais vous
pouvez au grade et ça en fait si vous
êtes bon dans le calcul mental
si c'est pas le cas regardez mes vidéos
sur le calcul mental je donne qu'un
astuces ça vous permet d'avoir un score
plus parlant voilà c'est tout pour ce
master class qui était consacrée au
comptage des cartes au blackjack
encore une fois ne fait pas des 10 avec
elle n'allait pas dans les casinos pour
tricher avec ça entraînez vous pour vous
pour votre culture personnelle c'est
intéressant bien sûr abonnez-vous à la
chaîne youtube c'est très important
vous pouvez aussi en profiter pour
regarder la vidéo où je suis avec jane
russel où je suis avec céline ou celle
où je suis avec laeticia voilà qu'on les
avait vus en début de vidéo je sais pas
si on les entendra trop mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle parle
j'entends parler de lifestyle de bain
dérivatif de bio on s'éclate à la maison
aujourd'hui
abonnez-vous objectif 2500 abonnés à
2500 abonnés ont c'est un apéro virtuel
je pense que je vais utiliser périscope
et on va se faire un live de quelques
heures ensemble on va pouvoir discuter
faire des trucs de mentalisme mais pour
ça faut qu'on soit 2500 j'ai vraiment
hâte que ça arrive je pense qu'on va
passer un bon moment
plus ça va plus je me dis mais en fait
ça va durer ça va durer 4h 5h mais c'est
pas grave ça va être cool j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu si c'est le cas
pense à la partager ça aussi c'est
important c'est ce qui fait connaître la
chaîne à tout le monde
et rendez vous demain à 11h pour
prochain mentale blog avec une
explication de mentalisme ciao